[Music]
and we're
rolling VOA some of you a lot of you
might know VOA you've probably seen his
videos on YouTube and Facebook VOA
happens to be in Guatemala at the same
time it's me and he's come here to San
Marcos so we can play and make a couple
videos so we're going to do a video
right now about how I show people in
person to either learn hyper Loops or to
get out of orbitals and I have a process
that works like this I'll we we're going
to pretend vo is actually new at this
but he's he's not so I'll tell the
person to really plant their feet and
say don't move your feet and your arms
are going to be like this and you're
just going to turn like this that's all
you're going to do I'm going to animate
your POI for you right so you hold the
handles I'm going to move the POI so
you're just going to turn when I you
know with me as I walk come with me so
he's spinning along you're spinning
along and the PO you're going to start
connecting here now if you start to turn
they come to the center the orange comes
up once the green comes up now if you
were to keep
turning They Come Undone only if this
hand pulls back a little bit because
what a lot of people do they keep
reaching that hand and then the pois
stays
trapped so what has to happen is when
you turn you have to end up exactly but
not too far apart just like that yeah so
let's do it again so that's the orange
CS up once he keeps turning the green
and he keeps
turning and they just come undone the
green can lead in green orange and
before the green come up again it can
turn now you can do doubles which I
recommend learning which is where orange
comes up once green comes up once orange
twice green twice and before the orange
can come up again turn
yeah or same thing the other way green
orange green uh orange and then before
it can finish
wh so basically the trick is if the
orange leads in the orange has to lead
out if the green leads in the green has
to lead out the reason is this
watch orange leads in green right now
before the there's orange on top if he
turns it'll come
undone if he did an extra half circle
and he turns it can't come undone right
if the Orange is hooked and the green
see they're both hooked here they can
come
undone here they can't if he turns
they're
caught so in the beginning at first I
recommend just first you learn a single
where it's orange once green once and
you get undone before the orange can go
again and I mean coming you know up to
Center or if the green leads in the
green comes up the center of his body
then the orange and the next time the
green comes up it's outside his hand
right then you learn to do doubles two
each and then triples three each
eventually if he leads in with the
orange and he were to pull gently they'd
start going really fast boom boom that's
an orbital too fast to count them swish
swish swish then if he let his hands go
back together a little bit that's what I
do it would slow down again then he has
to look and see this where the Orange is
on top now you can just
see also there's a bit of a wobble to
the whole move because as he's going see
when it's in this position the knot is
on an angle like
this and now it's on an angle like that
right it's on an angle like this it's on
an angle like that you'll learn to see
and feel that
wobble then you'll learn how to goes
wobble wobble wobble wobble
wobble from each Direction you just
learn and it just takes time but you
learn to feel when that's coming and how
to get out of
it so it totally takes time um I'm going
to demonstrate a couple of those um here
I'll show
so that's the a double so see the orange
leads in once twice and out I can let
the green lead in it come up once twice
and out it could be orange once and out
green once and out or orange one 2 three
and out but what doesn't work is to go
orange two and then finish see it's hard
to do it the wrong way now
H yeah actually I can't do it wrong
anymore but uh take turns find a friend
take turns and uh you may find this very
helpful to actually do it in three
dimensions
nice all
right it was better I think